.
Das ist Samira.
Auf ihrem Weg zur Diplomatin
stünde Kairo als Station
auf dem Programm.
Dort sollte sie
ihr Auslandpraktikum absolvieren.
Aber eben: sollte.
Es gab einige Änderungen.
Und zwar bin ich schwanger.
Ich hoffe sehr, dass ich
die gleiche Leistung bringen kann,
wie ich es gewohnt bin
und ich es gekonnt hätte,
denke ich, ohne Kind.
Es wird nicht einfach,
Kind und Karriere zu kombinieren.
Aber Samira
will es unbedingt schaffen.
* Feierliche Streicherklänge *
* Dramatische Streicherklänge *
Hold on!
Are you at the Swiss club?
C'est la, c'est la.
Este es mi machete,
Spickzettel, auf Deutsch.
Du bist Krisenmanager.
- Yes, are you here?
Yala, yala.
Diplomatie ist in der Schweiz
nicht besonders beliebt.
Man kennt uns nicht gut. Das ist
vielleicht auch unsere Schuld.
And a toast together.
(Ignazio Cassis) Auf Sie zählen wir
während der nächsten Jahrzehnte.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Die Stimmung ist sehr international,
Menschen aus der ganzen Welt
und viele internationale Organisa-
tionen sind hier. Mir gefällt das.
Zum Concours diplomatique,
der zweijährigen Diplomatenausbildung
von Alexander,
gehört die Arbeit
am UNO-Sitz in Genf.
Heute geht es
um einen ganz besonderen Auftrag.
* Dramatische Klänge *
Wenn sie dort hineingehen,
müssen wir dafür sorgen,
dass jemand bei den Liften steht.
Einfach,
damit wir zwei Lifte behalten.
damit wir zwei Lifte haben,
wenn er kommt.
Dann können sie runtergehen in den
zweiten Stock und unten reingehen.
Alexander und seine Crew warten
auf Prinz Hassan von Jordanien.
Der Prinz kommt auch noch an.
Wir organisieren gerade, dass man
hinten durch den VIP-Eingang kann,
da die Security, die Sicherheit des
Prinzen, das speziell gewünscht hat.
Jetzt müssen wir dafür sorgen,
dass alles reibungslos abläuft.
Jetzt kommt er.
Da ist er, der wichtigste Gast.
Der Prinz soll heute als Vorsitzender
des UN-Gremiums für Wasser
einen Vortrag zu diesem Thema halten.
Alexander soll den hochrangigen
jordanischen Wasserexperten empfangen
und ihn sicher und pünktlich
zwei Etagen tiefer in den
Konferenzsaal begleiten.
* Leise, angespannte Klänge *
Alle warten auf den Prinzen.
Aber der ist irgendwie verschwunden.
Eine sehr lange Liftfahrt.
C'est B2, pas deux.
L'autre ascenseur est B2.
- (Frau) Ah, ce n'est pas le meme?
Bon.
... les details ...
Wir hatten etwas Verspätung
mit dem Lift, aber sonst war es gut.
Ja, es ist interessant,
weil beim einen Lift die Nummern
anders sind als beim andern.
Wir testeten nur den einen Lift
und landeten auf der falschen Etage.
Das ist aber kein Problem.
Gerade noch geschafft.
Mit seinem Vortrag über
die politische Bedeutung von Wasser
kann Prinz Hassan pünktlich starten.
* Beschauliche Klänge *
Weihnachten feiern
bedeutet für Cristina,
Zeit im Unterengadin zu verbringen.
Mit ihrer Zwillingsschwester
Francesca,
die für Cristina
eine wichtige Bezugsperson ist.
Als Zwillingsschwestern hatten es
die beiden aber nicht immer leicht.
Dort drüben ist noch einer.
Als es um den Übertritt
ins Gymnasium ging,
sagten wir: "Wir wollen
nicht mehr in die gleiche Klasse."
In der Sekundarschule,
als man neu zusammengesetzt wurde,
war es schon so, dass wir
immer die Verones-Zwillinge waren.
Wir fanden: "Das wollen wir
nicht noch mal." Eigentlich ...
Darum sind wir dann auch bewusst ...
Francesca besuchte das mathematisch-
naturwissenschaftliche Gymnasium,
ich das sprachliche.
Wir haben das ...
Bewusst ...
... bewusst gewählt,
um - falls die Klassen
neu gemischt würden -
nicht in die gleiche Klasse
zu kommen.
Wir waren immer ...
Wir haben fast eine Münze geworfen.
Wir hatten fast die gleichen Noten.
- Du warst etwas besser in Mathe.
Darum ging sie ins Mathe-Gymnasium.
- Man hätte es auch anders ...
Wir haben einander immer angespornt.
Nicht im negativen Sinn, so:
"Jetzt war ich besser."
Genau.
- "Ich bin besser als sie."
Nie.
Die festliche Dekoration
ist das Fachgebiet von Mama Verones.
Das ist Tischdeko,
das nehmen wir nicht.
Die auch nicht, das sind so Blätter.
- Das ist auch für die Tischdeko.
Nein, die werden feucht.
Dekorieren geht dann
doch nicht ganz ohne diskutieren.
Die passen aber farblich nicht,
die roten.
Aber dann passt der Fliegenpilz
auch nicht.
Das passt schon. Es passt zu dem.
- Ja, also.
Ich würde den Bären zuoberst.
Den da. Gut.
Bei Familie Verones
stimmt alles bis ins kleinste Detail.
Und die nächste Generation
ist bereits in den Startlöchern.
Cristina ist seit sieben Monaten
Tante der kleinen Leonie.
So, wer möchte ein Stück?
- Ich.
Mal schauen,
ob es innen gut aussieht.
Ja.
(Mann) Ist das so ein Branchli ...?
- Ein Mississippicake.
Danke.
Die ganze Familie
ist sehr stolz darauf,
dass Cristina die Ausbildung
zur Diplomatin machen kann.
Ihr Vater weiss genau,
woher seine Tochter
den starken Willen
und die Leistungsbereitschaft hat.
Das ist schon mütterlicherseits.
V.a. auch ... die Grossmutter
mütterlicherseits.
Beide, also die Mutter von Cristina
und die Grossmutter,
sind sehr vielseitige Frauen,
die unglaublich viel
geleistet haben.
Ich würde schon sagen ...
- Vielen Dank für die Blumen.
Etwas wird Cristina bald
lernen müssen: Abschied nehmen.
Das gehört zum Diplomatinnenleben.
Schon bald geht es
für 15 Monate nach New York
für ihre praktische Ausbildung.
* Kullernde, gezupfte Klänge *
Heute geht es um
die Königsdisziplin der Diplomatie.
Die jungen Diplomaten lernen heute,
wie man verhandelt.
V.a. für Jonas ein wichtiger Tag.
Als studierter Physiker ist er eher
ein Exot im diplomatischen Geschäft.
Aber es gibt da einen, der wie Jonas
Naturwissenschaftler ist:
der ehemalige Spitzendiplomat
Michael Ambühl.
Ich vertraue darauf, dass wir
hier unter uns sind, en famille,
dass wir auch eine gewisse
Vertraulichkeit pflegen können.
Kommt der Schweizer Finanzplatz
unter Beschuss, ist er gefordert.
(O-Ton) "Wunderwaffe",
"Mr. Steuerdeal", "Pokerface".
Wir verhandeln immer hartnäckig.
Der Diplomatie hat Michael Ambühl
seine Karriere verschrieben.
Der Aufstieg verlief steil.
Er gehörte zur Delegation,
die für die Schweiz die Bilateralen
mit der EU aushandelte.
Gut, jetzt gehen wir ...
Gibt es dazu noch Fragen?
Nein? Voila.
Okay, jetzt geht es los.
Die Einführung:
Bei den Guten Diensten
gibt es zweierlei Kategorien.
Meine Chefin im EDA, Frau Calmy-Rey,
hat mir immer gesagt:
"Monsieur Ambühl, on n'est pas la
pour servir le cafe."
Das habe ich mir gut gemerkt,
diese schöne Formulierung.
Er hier
hat jetzt nur "servir le cafe",
hat es dann aber trotzdem -
unverdienterweise, wie ich finde -
auf ein solch prestigeträchtiges
Bild geschafft.
Aber was Sie pachten müssen,
sind die Kenntnisse in einzelnen
Dossiers, die Sachkenntnisse,
und Sie müssen die Fähigkeit
haben, das zu generalisieren
und es
auf die politische Ebene zu heben.
Voila. Wie viel Pause?
Bis um halb? Länger?
(Mann) Bis um halb ist gut.
Also, 10.30 Uhr.
Gut.
Ich habe wirklich
sehr grossen Respekt vor ihm.
Ich empfinde es
wirklich als grosses Privileg,
dass wir jetzt von ihm ...
lernen dürfen.
Er ist einer der besten Verhandler,
den die Schweiz je gesehen hat.
Jetzt gibt es eine Gelegenheit
für Jonas,
sich direkt mit seinem Vorbild
auszutauschen.
Wenn man Komplexität
einigermassen darstellen kann,
hat man schon etwas erreicht.
Wir haben doch halb gesagt.
- Ja, daran müssen wir uns halten.
Als Grundlage haben Sie
immer den Utilitarismus, oder?
Bei der Spieltheorie?
- Letztlich ja.
Ja, ja.
Aber dann könnte man theoretisch
auch modifizierte Formen
der grundlegenden Moralphilosophie
wählen
und diese sozusagen in eine alter-
native Spieltheorie reinformulieren?
Kann man so sagen, ja.
Für uns ist das
natürlich extrem spannend,
wenn wir aus Ihrer Praxis sehen,
wie Sie sich all diese
Verhandlungsstrategien zurechtlegen
und sie ... verfolgen.
Ja, ich versuche das Beste.
Ich fand immer sehr faszinierend,
welchen Zugang zur Diplomatie
Herr Ambühl hat.
Insofern war es wirklich
eine Inspiration für mich.
Verhandeln müssen Schweizer
Diplomatinnen und Diplomaten
besonders gut können: Da unser Land
z.B. nicht in der EU ist,
braucht es viel mehr Verträge und
deshalb auch viel mehr Verhandlungen.
* Sanfte, vibrierende Klänge *
Auch Samira
ist heute bei einer UNO-Konferenz.
Sie musste sich in ein
ziemlich komplexes Thema einlesen.
Es geht um autonome Waffensysteme.
Sie muss heute die Positionen
der einzelnen Länder zusammentragen.
Auf Französisch
wird es immer länger.
Ich habe nur 6 Min. Zeit für diesen
riesigen Text auf Französisch.
Ein Arbeitskollege von Samira ist da,
um sie zu unterstützen,
falls sie Fragen hätte
zu Inhalt oder Ablauf der Konferenz.
Los geht's.
Gut, dann fangen wir an.
Genau. Jetzt bin ich gespannt.
Jetzt noch das Earpiece rein.
- (Flüsternd) Genau.
(O-Ton) Hier am Genfer UNO-Sitz
diskutieren Regierungsexperten
noch bis Freitag über den Umgang
mit autonomen Waffensystemen.
Hier hat kein Soldat mehr
den Finger am Abzug.
Waffensysteme wie dieses
beschäftigen die Staatengemeinschaft:
autonome Waffensysteme.
Im Saal ist es jetzt eigentlich
mehr eine Ausbildungsphase.
Wir zeigen ihr jetzt, wie das
mit dieser Konferenz funktioniert.
Ich habe v.a. den verschiedenen
Statements zugehört und versucht,
die Positionen herauszuarbeiten.
Welche Staaten wollen ein Verbot
der autonomen Waffen?
Gibt es Staaten, die eine
differenzierte Position einnehmen?
Ein bisschen einteilen in die Camps,
die es zurzeit gibt.
Eine Pause
ist für Samira besonders wichtig:
Sie ist im siebten Monat schwanger.
Ich brauche gerade
einen Vitaminschub.
Ich bin gerade ziemlich kaputt.
Bei multilateral
macht man meist über Mittag durch.
Man hat keine richtige Mittagspause.
Schnell ein Sandwich, und weiter!
Klar möchte ich so lange
wie möglich einsatzfähig bleiben,
aber ich höre
auch auf meinen Körper.
Wenn der plötzlich sagt, es gehe
nicht mehr ... Dann wäre das so.
Aber klar, man will
einen guten Eindruck hinterlassen.
Alles, was Samira macht,
wird beurteilt und ist wichtig,
wenn es am Schluss ums Bestehen
der diplomatischen Ausbildung geht.
* Sanfte, vibrierende Klänge *
Das bedeutet für Jonas Heimat.
Mh, die sind extrem lecker.
(Katrin) Ja, ich nehme auch eine.
Ich glaube,
die mag sie noch nicht so.
Sharing is caring.
* Jonas lacht. *
Das war's.
Wer als Diplomat leben will,
ist immer wieder auf der Durchreise.
In einer Woche
beginnt er als Diplomaten-Stagiaire
auf der Botschaft in Buenos Aires.
Für ihn, aber auch für
seine Partnerin nicht so einfach.
Schau dort oben, Celestine.
Da dreht es immer.
Ganz viele Bären, die drehen.
Jede Stunde gehen sie um den Kreis.
Es war nicht einfach, in der kurzen
Zeit wirklich etwas aufzubauen.
Katrin hätte gerne
als Gitarrenlehrerin gearbeitet.
Ich hatte hier
jetzt auch Angebote bekommen
für gute Lehrerstellen,
aber ich konnte sie nicht annehmen.
Genau.
Das fällt dann schon auch
ein bisschen schwer.
Ich muss halt sehr, sehr kämpfen,
dass ...
Ich kann
noch nicht wirklich Spanisch,
kann meinen Unterricht
nur auf Englisch anbieten.
Und Konzerte, das geht immer.
Musik kann man spielen.
Aber auch die Verbindungen, die
Kontakte zu knüpfen, braucht Zeit.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Es ist die Entscheidung
für eine Lebensform.
Es ist etwas anderes, als wenn man
eine Stelle annimmt und sich sagt:
"Jetzt mache ich das ein paar Jahre,
danach wieder etwas anderes."
Hier entscheidet man sich
wirklich für eine Lebensform,
die die ganze Familie einbezieht.
Das ist sicher
eine der grossen Herausforderungen.
* Entspannte, fröhliche Klänge *
Heute kochen wir ...
einige Currys aus Sri Lanka.
Je crois que c'est celle-la.
- Ah, oui.
Jean-Baptiste
ist seit der Kantonsschule
mit Julien und Jerome befreundet.
Später haben sie zusammen das Opern-
haus Louise in Freiburg gegründet.
Krisztina kennt Jean-Baptiste
aus einem früheren Job.
Er ist gerne Gastgeber.
Und leidenschaftlicher Koch.
Ja, ich muss den Fokus ein bisschen
auf diese Zutatenliste legen.
* Lachen *
Too many cooks in the kitchen.
Jetzt sind wir schon zu zweit.
Dann verliere ich evtl. etwas
die Kontrolle über die Operation.
Und das wird dann kritisch.
Das ist so.
Kontrollfreak?
Bin ich Kontrollfreak in der Küche?
Du bist ein Kontrollfreak.
- Aber nur in der Küche.
Du hast deinen Bereich: "Da bin ich
in meinem Königsbereich."
"Da möchte ich lieber keine Hilfe,
da sonst meine Routine gestört ist."
Ja, das stimmt.
Freundschaften
regelmässig zu pflegen,
ist mit einem internationalen
Diplomatenleben sehr schwierig.
(Krisztina) Jean-Baptiste,
wir werden wirklich verwöhnt.
Er interessiert sich sehr
für die Leute.
Das ist natürlich
ein Vorteil in diesem Beruf.
Es ist etwas,
das dich sehr sympathisch macht.
Die Leute
haben gerne deine Aufmerksamkeit.
Nein, du schenkst den Leuten
deine Aufmerksamkeit ...
Du bist grosszügig.
- Das ist nett, dass du das sagst.
Nein, ich sage das nicht,
um nett zu sein, aber ich ...
Die Mehrheit ist nicht so wie er,
das ist klar. Umso besser.
Ich bin froh, haben sie ein Persön-
lichkeit wie Jean-Baptiste gewählt.
Ich bin sehr traurig, dass er geht.
Ich möchte noch viele Leute sehen.
Ich treffe mich jedes Wochenende
mit Familie, Freunden,
am Abend noch, in Bern.
Volle Pulle.
Irgendwann kommt dann der
reality check: Okay, du gehst jetzt.
Bald wird Jean-Baptiste nach
Westafrika, in den Senegal reisen.
Aber vorher verabschiedet er sich
auch von seiner Heimatstadt Freiburg.
Das heisst für ihn,
nochmals so richtig auszugehen.
Dann verlasse ich meine Umgebung,
meine Komfortzone,
ich verlasse die Freundin,
die Familie, die Freunde,
Fri-Son.
Ja, es sind gemischte Gefühle,
aber ich liebe das.
* Sanfter Elektropopsong: "Landscape
Escape" von Odd Beholder *
# ... chemical reaction,
# it looks like the fire.
Je mehr man ausreisst,
desto mehr braucht man einen Ort,
an dem man sich wohl fühlt,
zu Hause.
Heimat ist für mich Fribourg. Fri-
Son ist ein wichtiger Teil davon.
# ... feels so strange to be alive.
Auch Alexander verabschiedet sich -
von seiner Familie.
Ihr habt gesagt,
ihr kommt im Januar.
Ja, sobald du installiert bist
und weisst, wie es geht
und wann es
klimatisch am besten ist.
November bis Januar
ist nicht schlecht.
Naja, jetzt lebst du dich mal ein,
schaust und machst und tust.
Genau.
Ich gebe euch Bescheid,
wenn ihr kommen könnt.
Ciao, Lexi, mach's gut.
Bye, bye. Danke für alles.
Wir hören uns.
Tschüssli, Ali, eine gute Zeit.
Bestens, tschüss, tschüss.
Für Alexander beginnt jetzt
ein neuer Lebensabschnitt.
Sein erster Job
als Diplomaten-Stagiaire im Ausland.
* Verträumte elektronische Klänge *
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Das ist jetzt mein Zuhause
für die nächsten 15 Monaten.
Es ist irgendwie
ein kribbeliges Gefühl.
Zu diesem neuen Leben
gehören auch einige Vorteile.
Es ist eine kürzere Schlange
beim Anstehen. Es geht schneller.
Good morning.
- Good morning.
Thank you very much.
Der Rest
kommt dann mit dem Möbeltransport.
Morning. Salut, ca va?
- Ca va, et toi?
Merci beaucoup pour etre venue.
Vraiment.
* Beschwingte Klavierklänge *
Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
Aufwachen in einem Land, das erst
seit acht Jahren nicht mehr isoliert
und vom Militär regiert wird.
53 Mio. Menschen, das bedeutet:
neue Freiheiten, viele Chancen,
aber auch grosse gesellschaftliche
und wirtschaftliche Probleme.
* Sanfte fernöstliche Klänge *
Thank you very much.
- You're welcome, Sir.
Thank you so much, Sir. Thank you.
Ich habe überall gelesen, dass
man das macht. Es ist etwas neu.
Ah, bonjour Agnes.
- Salut, Alexander. Bienvenu.
Une villa coloniale,
qui a de pres une centaine d'annees.
Tres, tres sympa, je pense.
- Je te laisserai t'installer.
C'est vraiment sympa ici.
L'ambassadeur Seger.
- Herr Botschafter.
Guten Tag.
- Guten Morgen. Alexander Scherrer.
Wie geht's? Gut gereist?
- Sehr gut, besten Dank.
Ich durfte noch kurz 1-2 Std.
schlafen. Deshalb wieder topfit.
Okay, welcome to the club.
Setz dich, bitte!
Tu veux t'assoir, toi aussi?
Ein Thema,
das hier gross im Schwange ist:
Man will aus Burma
ein demokratisches
und föderales Burma machen.
Das Wort Föderalismus selbst war
unter der Militärregierung tabu.
Wer das benutzte,
kam in den Knast.
Man muss sich bewusst sein, wel-
chen Wandel dieses Land erlebt hat -
in verhältnismässig kurzer Zeit.
Alexander will an der ersten Sitzung
einen guten Eindruck machen,
Müdigkeit hin oder her.
Nach dem Meeting geht es für den
Nachwuchsdiplomaten direkt weiter.
Seine direkte Vorgesetzte verteilt
bereits erste Aufgaben und Ämtchen.
Geht das so für dich?
Ja, das ist tipptopp.
EDA, Yangon, all Users.
Hier habe ich für dich
etwas zum Einlesen.
Dann die Hintergrundinformationen,
die die Botschaft immer zusammen-
stellt, die politische Synthese.
Wenn du siehst,
dass da etwas veraltet ist,
was man aktualisieren sollte -
please do. Look at it!
Ich schaue es mir an.
Die Vorbereitung
ist ganz, ganz wichtig.
Ich glaube, es hat auch etwas
mit persönlichem Stolz zu tun.
Im Sinne, dass man
eine Chance bekommen hat,
zwei Jahre
diese Ausbildung zu machen.
Man will auch rüberbringen, dass es
einen guten Grund dafür gibt,
ausgewählt worden zu sein.
Es geht vielleicht
auch ein wenig darum,
sich selbst zu beweisen,
dass es berechtigt ist,
dass man aufgenommen worden ist.
Wer die Schweiz
im Ausland vertreten will,
braucht einen starken Willen und
viel Ausdauer. Alexander hat beides.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Ich sehe es nicht.
* Hupen *
* Beschwingte Klänge *
Jean-Baptiste startet viel gemüt-
licher in seinen ersten Arbeitstag.
Er konnte sogar ausschlafen.
Ich freue mich.
Ich habe supergut geschlafen.
Endlich hatte ich ein bisschen Zeit.
Ah, das ist unser Chauffeur.
Voila, parfait.
Wenn du das erste Mal in einer Stadt
irgendwo auf der Welt bist,
diese erste Taxi-
oder Busfahrt bis zum ...
... Hotel oder so,
das finde ich immer super.
Während der nächsten 15 Monate
ist Dakar sein Zuhause.
Senegal in Westafrika,
eines der 25 ärmsten Länder der Welt.
Aber auch  d i e  Vorzeigedemokratie
auf dem afrikanischen Kontinent.
Bald trifft Jean-Baptiste
seine neue Chefin.
Nur wenn er sie überzeugen kann, wird
das was mit dem Diplomatenstatus.
Ich bin gespannt.
Und das ist sie,
Botschafterin Marion Weichelt.
Voila. J'ose entrer.
Bonjour Madame.
- Norma Schenker, Kanzleichefin.
Jean-Baptiste Deleze,
Diplomaten-Stagiaire.
Jean-Baptiste,
enchante de vous rencontrer enfin.
Ich lass dich bei Norma.
- Merci.
Und hier gibt es ein Sitzungszimmer
an der frischen Luft.
Ja.
- Sehr schön.
* Entspannte Klänge *
Bonjour.
- Bonjour Madame.
Als Diplomaten-Stagiaire
muss Jean-Baptiste
der Zentrale in Bern berichten, wie
die politische Situation vor Ort ist.
Nicht nur in Senegal, sondern auch in
Nachbarländern wie Mali oder Guinea.
Seine Hauptthemen
sind die Wassersituation im Land
und die Präsidentschaftswahlen
nächstes Jahr.
(Frau) Ja?
Darf ich?
- Natürlich.
Merci.
Bitte, nimm Platz!
Merci beaucoup.
- Ähm ...
Da? Das wäre dein Platz. Gut.
Normalerweise.
Kein Problem.
Und? Alle kennengelernt.
Ja, fast alle.
Zumindest alle, die da sind.
Merci.
- Voila.
Mir ist es sehr wichtig,
dass immer
eine kurze Notiz gemacht wird.
Selbst wenn nur darin steht:
"Ich habe dann und dann
die und die Person getroffen
und über das und das gesprochen."
Und zwar im Sinne der
Nachvollziehbarkeit des Dossiers.
Sehr schön. Ich sehe,
dass es schon viel Inhalt gibt. Wow.
Ja, ja. Es gibt Arbeit.
Ich sehe verschiedene Länder.
Nicht nur Senegal,
sondern auch Mali, Kap Verde,
Guinea-Bissau - wow, okay.
Das ist nicht ein Programm,
das ich mir ausgedacht habe,
um ihn zu beschäftigen.
Und wenn er nicht da wäre,
würden wir es ohne ihn machen.
Aber ich bin froh, dass er da ist.
Da ist für mich ganz wichtig,
dass er wirklich mitzieht.
Ich schätze die Vielfältigkeit.
Für uns Stagiaires
ist herausfordernd,
dass wir Unterschiedlichstes machen
müssen innerhalb von gut einem Jahr.
Ganz genau.
- Das ... ist hier klar reflektiert.
Super. Sehr gut.
- Merci infiniment.
Viel Erfolg bei der Wohnungssuche.
- Merci.
Ich freue mich
auf die Zusammenarbeit, wirklich.
Ganz meinerseits.
- Merci beaucoup, Marion.
* Langsame Western-Klänge *
Ich bin der Neue, bin da,
um zu lernen, bin der Stagiaire.
Ich habe schon gemerkt,
da kamen Dossiers:
"Du wirst das und das machen,
da ist noch eine Reise,
und, und, und."
Find ich super, spannend,
aber auch herausfordernd, das schon.
* Schnelle spanische Gitarrenklänge *
Jonas ist seit einem Monat ohne seine
Familie in Buenos Aires im Praktikum.
Morgen kommen seine Partnerin Katrin
und Tochter Celestine hier an.
Man sagt, wenn ein Kind
an einen neuen Ort kommt,
dass es gut ist, wenn man
ein spannendes Spielzeug hat
oder etwas,
das dem Kind Freude bereitet,
da es sich so am neuen Ort
sofort zu Hause fühlt.
* Lautsprecherdurchsage
auf Spanisch *
Wow!
Ein Puppenwagen wäre perfekt.
Aber wenn ich das anschaue, ist es
schon nicht die beste Qualität.
Ich möchte einfach nicht, dass sie
eine Schraube in den Hals bekommt.
Genau.
Aber das sieht gut aus.
Da kann sie ihre Puppe reinlegen
und sie herumfahren.
Sie freut sich mega,
wenn sie etwas herumschieben kann.
Das ist so die Hauptsache.
Es muy lindo, gracias.
- De nada. Chao.
Chao.
* Sanfte, gläserne Klänge *
Jonas macht sich Gedanken,
wie das Leben mit Frau und Kind
in dieser fremden Grossstadt wird.
Es ist klar,
es ist nicht ein Nine-to-five-Job.
Man muss sich bewusst sein, dass es
auch abends mal länger dauert
und es abends
auch mal einen Anlass geben wird.
Aber wir
haben das gemeinsam beschlossen.
Von daher ...
Man muss sich dessen bewusst sein.
Eine Wohnung
hat Jonas bereits gefunden.
Eine fixfertig möblierte Wohnung.
Hier sollen sich
Katrin und Celestine wohlfühlen.
Das ist sehr wichtig,
weil gerade Katrin in Bern
beruflich nie richtig zufrieden war.
Sie konnte einen
sehr tollen Job nicht annehmen,
weil wir hierherziehen.
Es ist nicht ganz einfach,
das Umfeld zu wechseln, vielleicht.
Deshalb hoffe ich umso mehr,
dass sie jetzt hier
eine erfüllende Aufgabe finden wird.
Kommt das gut?
Kann sich Katrin
hier wirklich einleben?
Das in der nächsten Folge
von "Die jungen Diplomaten".
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Elisabeth Graf - 2019